[Musik]
ich bin den blöcken ja sowieso manche
menschen sind durchschaubar
plötzlich redet er zuviel die auch
nervös und die hände von an zu zittern
andere spieler sind selbst für profis
und durchschaubar und waren ihr
pokerface
[Musik]
für viele ist volker nur ein glücksspiel
für andere ist es jedoch ein denksport
bei dem die richtige strategie zum
schnellen reichtum führt können oder
glück genau das möchte ich herausfinden
kann ich als anfänger mit online poker
geld verdienen für dieses experiment
betrachten wir pokern als vermeintlichen
denksport innerhalb von einer woche
versuche ich strategien tricks und mind
games heraus zu finden mit denen ich
anderen echten spielern echtes geld
bequem von zu hause aus der tasche
ziehen kann mein einsatz 1000 dollar
dieses video wird unterstützt von meinem
schnittkurs mit dem ihr über den link in
der beschreibung innerhalb von wenigen
stunden so oft ihr wollt und ganz ohne
abo das schneiden von musik youtube &
travel videos lernen jetzt exklusiv für
kanal mitglieder 30 prozent rabatt
alle infos in der beschreibung mit
wenigen klicks ist das online poker
konto erstellt und es kann losgehen
pokern gegen millionen von spielern
weltweit vorerst zum trainieren
natürlich mit spielgeld
das ist unser platz 28
wie ich höre dir etwa 100 dann steigt
aus er steigt auch aus okay er erhöht
sogar 200 mal mit ok was macht da 850
was eigentlich mal drauf ankommt der
bluff bestimmt nicht aus dass es mir zu
wild zwei asse ich setz 100 ersetzt 4000
der bfd ich gehe mit o&o also ob poker
jetzt glück oder können ist habe ich
noch die noch nicht herausgefunden aber
ich habe herausgefunden dass wenn man so
lost ist wie ich dass man jedenfalls
immer verlieren also schaue ich jetzt
das allererste mal was über hauptsache
ist die spielvariante texas hold'em für
die ich mich entschieden habe
funktioniert grobe so jeder spieler
startet mit einer bestimmten anzahl an
chips oder geld und bekommt am anfang
der runde zwei karten auf die hand
nacheinander werden in der mitte des
tisches rundenbasiert zuerst die ersten
drei dann die vierte und dann die fünfte
karte aufgedeckt jedes mal kann einen
spieler reihum seinen einsatz erhöhen
und andere können entweder mitgehen oder
aussteigen je nachdem wie sehr ihnen die
aufgedeckten karten in die hand spielen
am ende gewinnt der der unter verwendung
der gemeinschafts karten in der mitte
grund seiner eigenen karten auf der hand
die beste 5er kombination hat der wert
der einzelnen karten steigt von 2 34 bis
zu dame könig und es die schlechteste
kombination ist keine kombination also
die icard dann kommt das paar das
doppelte paar ein dreier paar eine
straße bzw einen straight flush ein full
house dann ein 4 apa ein straight flush
und zu guter letzt das royal flush ein
straight gebildet aus den
höchstmöglichen karten und das
ausgleichen symbolen
[Musik]
so ich werde jetzt zum allerersten mal
mit echtgeld spielen spiegelt wäre auf
echtgeld umgesetzt
wir gehen auf kasse und einzahlungen ja
[Musik]
wir haben jetzt hier 1000 dollar auf
jetzt spielen
ok jetzt bin ich wirklich gespannt was
ihr konto wurde wegen einer ausstehenden
routinemäßiger sicherheitsprüfung
vorübergehend eingeschränkt unschuldigen
uns dafür jetzt keine mitspielen man gut
dann rufe ich mal wieder im laden an
ich habe jetzt mit meiner bank angerufen
und die meinten da ist alles okay das
heißt ein geld ist jetzt auf dem konto
eingefroren und ich muss hoffen dass ich
es jemals wieder irgendwie in die finger
kriegt stark was soll das denn
naja was soll es inzwischen zwar habe
ich mich bei einem anderen online poker
dienst angemeldet und da erst mal 100
dollar angezahlt jawohl das immer so das
ist schon ganz anderes gefühl wenn jetzt
darum plötzlich dollar steht und nicht
mehr nur spiegelt mitgehen ersetzt
direkten euro da bin ich komplett raus
mal drei euro madouni er hat noch erhöht
ich bin raus okay er ist mitgegangen
wie schnell haben jetzt fünf euro
verloren ok zwar ist das nicht schlecht
die beat markt gleich ziehen sind oder
schnaps okay okay okay wir haben jetzt
drei asse oder save keiner besser ist
wie komme ich manchmal ein bisschen
risky mit 1 175 auf
da geht aber keine mit die wären alle
glaube ich okay abgewonnen ein bisschen
immerhin war das ist immer gut aus zwei
damen da geht nur mit krebs und
spannender 50 cent schauen wir dann auch
mitglied oder ist noch eine dame
okay okay und 22
oder 5 ok ich die rollen eigentlich die
ohren mal schauen was hat okay war
die hatten straight die mich abgezogen
eigentlich so wird das nix die ersten
zehn dollar will weg ich glaube ich
brauche einfach eine gute strategie es
gibt viele strategien eine sehr
grundlegende art des spielens die sich
zeit nimmt weil sie jetzt darauf dass
man nachdem man seine zwei statt karten
also die stadt hand bekommt auch einfach
aussteigen kann und gar kein geld
einsetzt aber woher weiß man ob eine
hand gut ist oder nicht man kann sich
dabei folgende fragen stellen erstens
sind die karten hoch 2 sind die karten
ein pärchen drittens liegen die karten
nah beieinander und könnten eine straße
bilden und viertens haben die karten das
gleiche symbol und könnten einen flush
bilden je mehr kriterien zutreffen desto
besser aussetzen sollte man also
komplett zusammenhangslose niedrige
karten wie 94 die unterschiedliche
symbole haben und zu weit auseinander
sind um eine straße zu bilden aber sogar
von kein plan sollte man sich nicht
hinreißen lassen spielbar sind hingegen
höhere paare wie 88 und sehr hohe und
aufeinander folgende karten wie könig
dame aus denen sich entweder ein hohes
paar oder eine straße entwickeln könnte
die luxe ende die unter allen umständen
gespielt werden sollten sind hohe paare
ab 10 10 ein ass und ein könig in
gleicher farbe und natürlich die
stärkste stadt hat überhaupt als als
schwächster hand gilt übrigens 27 in
unterschiedlichen farben daraus kann
sehr schwer eine straße gebildet werden
kein fleisch und die zahlen sind auch
noch sehr niedrig mit diesem wissen
sollte man eigentlich schon einen klaren
vorteil gegenüber jeden anfänger haben
und das setzt sich jetzt direkt mal in
die tat um und schaut ob ich jetzt
profit macht okay wir haben zwei asse
da ist wieder eine heikle nummer ich
erhöhe
und ich lese mir nach hause 36 cent pro
watt aber man merkt dass die leute mit
echtgeld ganz anders spielen viel mehr
strecken ersten wohne direkt aus weil
sich als schlechte karten haben wir
haben zwei damen das ist nicht schlecht
wirklich mit und erhöhte sogar noch mal
gewonnen
150 euro das sind zwei sehr gute karten
zwei buben wenn er erhöht heisst dass du
dir etwas gutes hat sonst würde hier mit
recht gelten die man erwähnen ich biete
zehn mal schauen ob er von seinem garten
überzeugt dass er steigt aus und ich
nehme die 72 cent mit ich will das mal
euro bleibe ich ihn raus rufe ich ihn
raus ja erst ich habe ihn rausgeworfen
und dann zu gewinnen das ist cool klar
für mich entschieden ich bin mit über 9
dollar abhängig mit das nicht schlecht
hier sind sehen dass starb ach das war
gar nicht gut ich die mit ok aber nichts
daraus geworden ist und ich bin wieder
ganz unten gut ich muss strikt bleiben
straits da bitte ich direkt mal für das
war zuviel der satz fiel die gehen jetzt
alle raus aber gut immerhin effekte
spiele ich besser machen können okay ich
gehe jetzt in die weißen vw golf war so
vorsichtig die ganze zeit und das waren
67 dann plötzlich weg ist so krass ich
nehme mir vor jetzt richtig strikt zu
sein aber es hat einfach nicht
hingehauen damit gegangen diesmal gar
keinen sinn
die sieben euro selber weg ich üben
meinung bisher meine emotionen im griff
zu kriegen ich spiele bis in den abend
und klar eine wichtige lektion wenn ich
mal gute karten habe und will dass die
mitspieler ihr geld einsetzen darf ich
in der ersten runde so gut wie nichts
setzen weil wir echt geld sonst jeder
sofort das handtuch wirft außerdem
stelle ich fest dass blöcken zwar am
meisten spaß macht wenn es klappt aber
leider auch viel zu oft daneben geht
misst und kann zwei bis drei uhr morgens
versuche ich die theorie in die tat
umzusetzen aber niedergeschlagen und mit
50 dollar verlust beende ich das ganze
und mache schluss für heute vielleicht
klappts morgen ja mit einem klaren kopf
besser
so und da setzt funktioniert können wir
jetzt raus kommen ich weiß ja das risiko
sich hier mal ausnahmsweise gelohnt habe
hier zwei buben das ist nicht verkehrt
nicht mal hier rein ich ja sowas von auf
die fresse kriegen ja ok ich muss ja
sicher 22 apa
die ist jetzt mal direkt 350 huhu huhu
okay sind jetzt gerade 12 dollar im pot
das macht ja und wir sind im plus und
zwar 350 die 27
wir nehmen auch mit ersatz gleichen euro
5,0 da ist noch jemand hat sich sowas
von 3g das ist ein sehr sehr starkes
blatt ich biete dir immer noch mal ja
der 150 geboten am 18
damit bleibt wird er auch handtuch dann
hatte ich ja trotzdem gelohnt hat sich
gelohnt und wir sind fünf euro im plus
das kann sich aber ganz schnell ändern
egal was habe ich denn jetzt grad für
die glückssträhne drei könige
da kann man ein bisschen was bieten 2008
ergebnis kann sich also ein bisschen
hoch x 250 mio okay er hat richtig was
angeboten
ich gehe mal mit ja er gewinnt um mein
gott er hat und schon sind wieder sechs
euro im minus und r8 oder ein könig und
dann habe ich eine straße mit
das wird teuer damit hat jetzt 40 euro
gewonnen schon wieder einen dreier
preismacht gar kein ich habe so gute
karten und trotzdem habe ich schon 20
euro jetzt verloren so kurzer zeit noch
1 10 okay ich habe 4 4 gegen ok dann
kann ich ja wohl jetzt nicht mehr um
mein gott geht all-in ok mache ich mir
mache ich mit weil ich ja da hat er sich
jetzt gewonnen hat ich habe wieder 14
euro im plus aber dann zögere ich
buchstäblich zu hoch und verleger 30
euro auf einem schlag doch manchmal ist
es auch extrem lukrativ zu prüfen
wenn wieder 60
das ist so eine achterbahnfahrt ok 13 da
muss man auch mit kenn ich habe sogar
nochmal geht damit erst von sich
überzeugt sonst eher nicht okay er
beläuft sich der hat nicht geblufft
und als wäre das noch nicht genug hat
mich ein starkes platz dazu verleitet
all in zu gehen und alles zu verlieren
was waren wir da etwas machen wir sagt
ich werde jetzt noch ein bisschen mit
meinen letzten 13 dollar vorsichtiger
spielen und das einüben und danach bin
ich lebe lang und muss restlichen 900
dollar
wir ziehen vorbei an tag 6 an dem ich
bin nie zuvor meine emotionen im griff
habe und weiterhin lernen wie man das
spielverhalten der spieler liest und
daraus schlüsse ziehen kann auch online
wir kommen zum grande finale dem moment
der wahrheit an dem nun unser gesamtes
verbleibendes konto aufs spiel gesetzt
wird ich bekomme wirklich das gefühl
eine kontrolle darüber zu haben und
besser zu werden aber genau das macht
mir am meisten angst und genau das ist
das gefährlichste an spielen die eine
große glücksspiel komponente haben
tag 7 heute ist mein letzter tag also
alles oder nichts wir haben immer noch
800 dollar auf dem konto und damit muss
jetzt was passieren
bisher habe ich immer so genannte cash
games gespielt mit relativ geringem
einsatz ab jetzt werde ich nur noch
turniere spielen mit einem einsatz von 1
bis 2 100 euro jeweils unter einem
riesigen preispool
jeder spieler der seine chips verliert
ist raus und der gewinner aber auch auf
der zweite und dritte bekommen die ganze
kohle
ich bin gerade einfach erst haben das
den 600 euro drin let's go o mein gott
als mitgegangen das wäre das dümmste im
leben überhaupt
ich habe es einfach nicht drauf okay
wenn jetzt kommt mein gott ich gewinne
weil ich gehört habe ist erst raus habe
ich rausgekickt ja ich verletzt und habe
ich wieder so hoch gekämpft nein da war
der 6 a
nein ich wurde zweiter das ist schon mal
stark habe jetzt hier mal ein einsatz
verdoppeln können und jetzt geht weiter
weil man die letzten tage und dann ist
spielen wir bei null sinn
[Musik]
es gibt weder das ich bin hier welt 24
dollar im plus
ich würde es gern weiterspielen ich
würde wirklich gerne weiterspielen
einfach aus dem grund weil ich diese
zahl gegen null gehen lassen würde damit
ich euch sagen kann haye macht es nicht
es ist riskant aber ich will das ist
noch eine bessere botschaft zu sagen
okay nicht nehmen was ich habe und hatte
dann quasi in dieser woche 40 prozent
gewinn gemacht hat man muss aufpassen
nicht in pokern könnte brandgefährlich
sein für mich einfach weil es in ihrem
viel mehr spaß macht was letztlich
glücksspiel wo ich einfach unten sand
gesetzt habe er ist eine person 1000
euro aus der tasche gezogen
da musste auch bisschen gekommen ich war
das noch ich zahle mir das geld direkt
aus natürlich in euro und nehme abschied
zu einem spannenden unterfangen welches
meine gesamte letzte woche bestimmt hat
wie schon am anfang erwähnt wird dieses
video von meinem eigenen schnittkurs
unterstützt der link dazu ist eine video
beschreibung viel wichtiger ist
allerdings dass meine kanal mitglieder
aktuell dafür 30% rabatt bekommen solche
aktion jetzt sehr oft geben auch dann
wenn ich mal merge rausbringe dass die
kahlen mitglieder die eben nicht auf
diesen kanal unterstützen neben lustigen
unnötigen bildern und videos auch
private auf mein merge oder eben jetzt
schon in diesem moment 30 prozent rabatt
auf diesen schnittkurs bekommen es ist
endlich soweit
nächste woche kommt das video in dem ich
veröffentliche wie viel geld ich mit
meiner eigenen app erwirtschaftet hat
und mies gemacht habe und wie es
weitergeht wenn ihr das nicht verpassen
möchte und schon vorher coole
ausschnitte daraus sehen möchtest folgt
nicht gerne auf instagram und abonniert
ist kanal wenn ihr mich auf diese weise
begleiten möchte und dann sehen uns
demnächst mal wieder macht's gut
[Musik]